good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
thank you for coming
many of you coming back to the third of
these Stimson lectures and the
international politics and and American
foreign policy and global affairs you
started starting the mid-to-late because
in the course of this week we have
variously method route two or three and
then brought down here then head of two
or three and now we're in the third one
we're back down here I think everybody
is not aware that were in this room was
this afternoon
since it was further the steps and
lectures introduced I'm not going to do
much more brief remark here we are
grateful to the anonymous donor of this
magnificent series of public lectures
which occurs at least once once in a
year time in honor of Henry Simpson one
of the greatest ladies and Secretary of
Secretary of Defense and Secretary of
State the lectures which are obtained in
religious Europe I my guest here
professor Christopher Andrew on the
theme of intelligence and intelligence
history we heard on Monday of the
language and the history of decrypting
and intelligence of developed first of
all in Asia moved across steadily to be
something after fifteen hundreds which
was more in the Western form of
statecraft and intelligence for for
politicians and for leaders and war we
heard on Tuesday wonderful talk about
the Anglo American intelligence history
and relationship from George Washington
writes
to the curveball and this third and
final Simpson lecture is to be given on
the theme of Russian service Russian
intelligence and Soviet intelligence
through until the end of the Cold War
professor andrew has distinguished
himself in a long career of writing a
whole series of books including a
British official history of intelligence
and the variety of works both British on
British American and Russian Soviet
intelligence well thank you very much my
intention is indeed to come up to the
present and as usual what I will be
trying to persuade is I think an axiom
that it's not really necessarily
persuade anybody in this circumstance
that anyone who attempts to interpret
the present in terms of the present is
bound to get it wrong but we all we know
that already so what I'm going to do is
to concentrate on the last hundred years
and to argue that Czarist intelligence
has an extraordinary influence on
Stalin's intelligence and that Stalin's
intelligence has an extraordinary
influence on Putin's intelligence and
that the area weathers intelligence this
extraordinary development has had most
impact is precisely in there the West so
we begin with this image which is I
suppose the most forgotten centenary in
international relations this year but
the look at the Lubyanka the current
head of putin's FSB and before that the
head of the KGB and before that the
first head of the checker curiously
unless during question time so he can
think of another one and somebody
possibly can this is the only
intelligence head
which has remained the same for the last
100 years and it shows no sign of of
moving home so here we are this is
Russia and the tsar nicholas ii and what
is extraordinary it seems to me I mean
the single thing that is most wrong
about the way that many people who were
sought to interpret the impact of
Russian intelligence on the outside
world is they've done it entirely in
terms of humans Russian spies appear to
be interesting you know the people of
Salisbury amongst others in Britain at
the present time but Russian code Burke
is attached attract a tiny fraction of
the interest of those who were at
Bletchley Park so I will try and put
that right Russia under tsar nicholas ii
was the world leader not simply the
european leader in SIGINT and
furthermore russia had a bigger lead in
second in my judgment then at any period
before or since
so why well it's very simple I mean the
best way to succeed SIGINT is be to be
extremely good at cryptanalysis but also
to cheat and the best way to cheat is
simply to exploit really poor security
in embassies which is which is why since
embassy security in some petersburg
because if there was and is now again
before the first world war was worse in
the British and American embassies the
easiest targets that Nicholas the second
Intelligence Service had were precisely
the British and the Americans so here we
are
George Mayer u.s. ambassadors in
Petersburg came in 1905 I have
discovered beyond the doubt that they
Russian government has in their
possession our entire white a Titan of
30 years to discover that is very
bizarre and of course exactly the same
thing happens in the British Embassy so
Charles Harding who goes on to be the
permanent head of the Foreign Office
misspelt by the way India in the fourth
line I just noticed while he was
ambassador they broke to the foreign
dolphin city it had a disagreeable shock
but again why nobody noticed this over
the previous 30 or 40 years but anyway
they hadn't a leading politician who
with whom he had dinner the previous
night quote did not mind how much I
reported in writing what he told me in
conversation but he begged me on no
account Telegraph as all that telegram
sir unknown they're the only odd thing
about that is it took them somewhat by
surprise there's no excuse for that but
the thing I think that most requires a
certain amount of revision in the
history of international relations
before the First World War are the
relations between these two people now
just look at the expression on the face
of nicholas ii and then look at the
silliest mustache of the facility first
world war period which is obviously the
kaiser on the right you can tell just by
looking at nicholas ii that he realizes
as many people did but the kaiser didn't
learn he was rather an idiot and you
could you could also see that the kaiser
thinks that he can pull one over on
nicholas ii without any difficulty so it
never occurred to the kaiser that this
man on whom he looked down was regularly
reading intercepted German diplomatic
telegrams and also making demeaning
comments about the Kaiser appropriately
debating comments about the Kaiser quite
similar to those which many historians
have made since so here we are shortly
off aliens reading those are nicholas ii
writes on a decrypted 1895 telegram from
berlin to the new German ambassador in
some petersburg childishly foolish
advice what did he think about the
Kaiser that he was Charlie Charlie's
defense now to my knowledge there's not
a single historian he would disagree
with him in our case but nicholas ii
arrived at that conclusion not a
brilliant man but he arrived at obvious
conclusion so that too much you know
differently and so
this I think makes it possible to look
at the July crisis which leads up to the
precipitates of the First World War
in a rather different way the British
have no code breakers at this point the
Germans have no code breakers acting at
this point the Americans barely know
what a Code Breaker is about the French
and the Russians know so this famous
meeting between Raymond poincaré the man
with the top hat the president of the
French Republic who was a man who looked
up to foreign policy and Nicolas a
second what are they discussing days
before the outbreak of the first world
war
seeking that's what they're discussing
and what are they most discussing well
we don't have the record of their
discussion but we know that they they
knew about had they had advanced
knowledge of the Austrian ultimatum to
Serbia how did they get that because the
Russians were decrypting the Austrian
communications and to the ambassador's
in Petersburg right now just a little
bit of background for what follows which
i think is apologists because we're well
known probably to just about everybody
here Lenin founds the checker a
forerunner of the KGB only six weeks
after Bolshevik Revolution under the
leadership of starlings friend Felix
Jasinski and I think it's been
insufficiently noticed just how close
friends they were of course what
happened throughout the early Cold War
was that the tallest statue which was
outside the Lubyanka which was the first
image I showed was not a name it was
known of Stalin
it was a Phoenix Jasinski and that is
why and the great symbol of the end of
the Soviet era is the pulling down of
Georgian skis statue so there he is
being trampled underfoot gives a good
example of just how big it was and there
he is being taken away to the graveyard
of statues on the
outskirts of Moscow but of course
they're now beginning to go up again and
this is not of the same size but it's
only a year ago and Kirov and it's it's
not the only one
so thanks mainly to Putin as Osinski
is back in favor but what tends to be
forgotten about Tim Putin is that ever
since he was a child now come on to this
in a moment as a teenager he was
obsessed and I think that's the accurate
verb he was obsessed with Russian
intelligence history Russian
intelligence history going back
centuries not simply during the Soviet
era there are many glorious pages right
examples of true heroism and courage in
the history of national security
organizations now from time to time he
will produce a nugget and what almost
always happens because we know custom to
this is that there is a message there
which we don't get immediately so here's
one example
Oh his subject he doesn't talk about
it's really rather interesting far happy
and talking about Soviet spies and
Cambridge Cambridge here then he is
about talking about Soviet spies in
Cambridge Massachusetts but what he
knows is that the penetration of MIT
began several years ahead of the
penetration of from Cambridge University
Cambridge here so there MIT which needs
and foreign students to at the beginning
of the 1930s in order to fill in places
that's not currently being taken up in
the depression it's the extraordinary
story so there we are this is the first
twenty three Russian students who
stopped on their way to MIT at New York
in order to buy suits and all of them
are either members of the Russian
intelligence services or reporting to
the Russian intelligence services so
there is Dean Tryon in the middle who
knows nothing of this two places to his
left is one of the most successful
intelligence office ever to operate in
the United States the one in the middle
between them journey apps gate just
shows one of the problems of stationing
American and Russian intelligence
officers of the United States in other
words that some of them will get to
enjoy it in to the United States so much
they will lose faith in their own system
so journey up ski whose lung just on the
right our left looking at it journey off
ski was actually recalled than executed
four years later but the man on his left
and this is the entry at the top from
the MIT yearbook since off Shawn boskie
it shows he was a student of the
yearbook and then you see him as an
intelligence officer once he's returned
to Russia years later was the most
successful I think spy in aviation in
the entire history of aviation has known
to me my knowledge is no comprehensive
now for the kind of thing that Putin
does talk about he likes to take us by
surprise and it's not too difficult
things to take us by surprise
so after this man George Koval died in
2006 without the West having grasped
that we really thought we view at that
point now all the people who have played
a major part in the single I suppose
most successful intelligence collection
operation in history that is to say the
collection of the plans for the first
atomic bomb which were then wholly
imitated by the Russians there was one
thing which we didn't realize that had
not been got by the people that we knew
and whilst the initiation I don't know
how to get an atomic bomb exploding but
I do know that you need an initiator and
this was a man who provided it George
Koval he was giu and not KGB like most
of the others and here is Putin but
shortly after his death were scarcely
drinks
he's raising a glass of champagne in
honor of Koval who he declares on the
spot hero of Russia now the timing is
very significant and we didn't get it at
the time so what do we get
well it was revealed about the initiator
there was polonium to 100 but
polonium-210 can be used for other
purposes and just three months before
[Music]
Putin announced that its contribution to
the first Russian atomic bomb
polonium-210 had been used to
assassinate a KGB and then if his be
defected to the Britain and it was
exactly the same as with the more recent
attempt to assassinate scruple they
spilt the stuff all over the place and
you can see from this map which there's
not time to and take in some of the
places that they spilt it as well as on
the plane on the way and in the plane
are on the way back and the chief assess
it just as the bunglers in Salisbury
more recently at both heroes of Russia
so the chief assassin here is currently
a member of the Russian parliament and
that's where the it's it's on the
tourist list for some people but you can
go out to the bar in the Millennium
Hotel and see where this poor man was
assassinated
so what Putin prefers to concentrate on
those with a rather more attractive
image and he so much prefers people from
Cambridge temperature then at Cambridge
Massachusetts for his propaganda
purposes so here is his Kim filming the
first and probably the most successful
member of the magnificence of five and
also the first British spy to get his
own postage stamp it was a Russian
postage stamp of course but there we are
and then there is the series of boils
pick a few and to celebrate the bankers
anniversary of the SVR Russian Foreign
Intelligence because
they take their foundation from 1920
which I could explain later when I would
stop to explain now they celebrate that
with actually a rather more interesting
memorials and Russians usually produce
to spy so here is kim Philby looking
both east and west which is quite nice
idea and fred cough is man on the right
at that point he was head of Russian
Foreign Intelligence and Philby's
Russian Widow is in the middle but only
last year it still goes on and he would
go up he has to come so early a year ago
the current SVR chief say again Irishman
opens a filthy exhibition in Moscow
public exhibition and there is Philby's
Widow and here she is getting the usual
compulsory bouquet so what was what was
Philby after well I think the most
difficult thing now to remember is that
otherwise highly intelligent people
could hero-worship
Stalin I mean I don't see any other way
of explaining why some of the brightest
to the best in Britain and it took
rather longer to be accepted in the
United States and decided to to work in
it but the images which appeared in the
media at the time which hardly anybody
was paying attention to sure here is
Stalin as a man of the people this is
from organic will some people and here
will will know
up until the in early 1930s he walked
around Moscow and it's he's such a
well-known figure that the picture and
there's so many that they're not all
certainly not all staged nobody is
paying particular attention to him now
compare that with the British prime
minister at the time ramasammy Ronald
Britain's first Labour Prime Minister
although first X Labour prime minister
at that time now he was the illegitimate
son of a Highland clammin and a Scottish
lady's maid but as soon as he moves into
number 10 as you seen he immediately
changes his dress
even dream of walking the quarter of
mile fool number 10 Downing Street to
Parliament now there is a limousine
which you can't see which takes him
there so Stalin is the first man of the
people in European history to walk
amongst other citizens we don't even
notice the photographs nowadays it's not
difficult looking back to see what any
impression that he made and there's
another one and again you know nobody is
particularly paying attention to him
now the other thing that has been
extraordinarily left out is Stalin's of
Khurana Russian Czarist in Intelligence
Service file serious as a quite not
looking at 23 year old Georgian
revolutionary probably they even though
there's I don't think this is relevant
category the best-looking revolutionary
of the of the time and these are the
people who are keeping track of him the
the most smartly dressed intelligence
service that I know of or Khurana and
the capital cost was some petersburg at
that point now people only just
beginning began looking at but I think
it's absolutely the central source for
beginning to understand starting it's a
hundred and twenty five volume file of
his Okhrana a volume of his okhrana file
and after the Revolution
Stalin moved it to his own archive where
it remains and it had the most all the
way through the he spent he must have
spent 20 years going through it and
annotating every page this happens to be
paid to have them a lot of doodles on it
I can't understand this but a colleague
who claims to be and I believe her says
that some of the things a teacher
teacher because he had been given the
title in Georgia of teacher of the
people and then there are a number of
references to a Moscow football team and
the others I can't I can't but
what will have astonished him is the
extraordinary intrusive level of
surveillance of his private life now his
first marriage I don't think there's
much doubt Polly was a love match I
don't think was capable of a love match
after his first wife died there's some
extraordinary evidence of this but he
did fancy a few friends fiance's and
here is one and he hasn't sent actually
from outside Russia to her and it
promises her a hot yes and when he finds
that in the file but it's usually this
is just an example going through his
entire life history up to 1917 and
seeing how it and being kept under
surveillance what did he send it on the
other side of the cart there is a it's
not particularly top-shelf to use
English terminology now but it's
something which would not have been
allowed to be posted in New York or in
London and he's sending it to the
sixteen-year-old
fiance of a friend well no time to go
through that
what other things affect him you know
here is somebody was a natural
conspiracy theorist and discovering the
people who he had trusted and being
betraying him for years is I think
something that has a permanent effect on
his mentality
so here's Roman malinovski malinovski in
was a rare example of a Bolshevik who
came from the working class and
government as they were so few of them
that he was given promotion in 1912 he's
head of the leader of the Bolshevik
fraction in the Duma and Lenin who was
rather spending a lot of time in England
to other places rather slow to realize
the level of penetration makes him head
of a 3-man provocation profit Katia
Commission to investigate the extent of
our prana penetration was Bolsheviks and
six months later
malinovski comes back and says well
we've concluded that there must be an
art rather spy very close to the
leadership of the Bolshevik Party
absolutely right the only thing he
forgot to mention is that it was him
know what of the things that would have
struck me and not simply me but perhaps
everyone here is that when the CIA
bungles pickles oh yeah it's the CIA
bundling when British intelligence
bundles people don't know it's British
intelligence bundling but when they
think the Russian intelligence Buggles
it's all sweet people say it shows just
how clever they ah they're pretending to
bungle so that we don't realize how
clever they are well Oh one's got to do
is get back to the linen period and see
a level of bundling which is beyond
anything in the history of the CIA or
mi6 or many other people and so here is
Lenin because of the most elementary
bundles linen actually becomes the file
is all there by the way they get it at
all controversial at an evidential level
of whether he becomes the first I think
still the only head of government or
head of state to be victim of a
carjacking so what's going on
he had a limousine he wasn't
tremendously fond of expensive objects
bill he had quite a nice car and he goes
to visit his long-suffering wife on the
outskirts of Moscow in 1919 but the
check our failed to provide a security
guard so what happens is exactly this
they stop by some bandits or the
outskirts of Moscow and Lenin says your
papers please probably doesn't say
please your papers to which the bandits
are calm right we're bandits bandits
don't have to have papers your wallet
please
you're a Browning pistol oh yes and your
car so he's left he's left on the
pavement if there was a pavement and
there probably wasn't good pavement
cuz I didn't catch the bandits despite
there was only one Liberty like this for
for six months so you know what went on
there is pretty much what's been going
on in Salisbury over the last year but
in the file for this also exists another
day when they fail to send anybody to
keep guard on linens study its
vandalized
22 we built a full report which was
drawn up by Jose in ski and he tells
people that they must look they must
identify those bits of his study which
were destroyed with chisels and those
that were destroyed with axes because
they leave different different parts so
but why it is that the brutality is is
well identified the power as well
identified but bundling we see the fight
more difficult to understand Russian
bungling than British or American Bundy
they when they really put their minds to
it or when they don't really put their
minds to it they can help bungalows any
day of the week now this is a
significant photograph try finding
pictures of Stalin with his round and
they really do like each other
so what then I imagine they're
discussing that I can't prove it and I
may easily be wrong they're discussing
their latest plans for an assassination
and they've concluded that it's really
no the Russian intelligence operator to
go after other countries and this has
made people there so what they must do
is get them to come to Russia where it's
much more convenient to assassinate them
and this is a remarkable picture well
the Sidney Riley that was so-called
British master spy wasn't any good by
that point they lure him back to Russia
and shoot him in 1925 but then they put
the corpse in the sick bay in the
Lubyanka and they have a drinks party so
you know the culture of assassination
even though it changes from generation
to generation it's a way about the
standing Salisbury or recently is to
take I think a long history into account
and of course Starling also has DC
strong relation so that the only one I
think he really really liked was Joe
Souki but the sheer statistics we can
get from his diary and agenda the fact
that at the height of the terror when he
had quite a lot on he meets years of 278
times for a total of eight hundred and
thirty four hours nearly always
including midnight but of course one of
the links I mean this was the period
when
brushing reaches its peak in European
history so now you see yourself and now
you don't and of course this is one of
the it still happens in Russia but as I
shall be showing at the the end of my
talk the airbrushing and the Putin is
now patch on what it was under Stalin
that sounds an exaggeration but I hope
to persuade you that it's not so what we
need to remember about all this is that
Stalin remained passionately interested
in ii know everybody knows that about
Churchill but I'm not aware that there's
a single book which makes the but to my
mind fairly obvious point that Stalin
was just as fascinated by at the SIGINT
as Churchill was so looking through
Stalin's personal files and the the blue
thing left to right and that's by the
way when Lincoln's the second he always
used to have a little blue ticker on
once that he'd seen it he says put it in
my archives and so it went
now the problem about such information
as has been made public
on Soviet sickened is that it's been
ludicrously dramatized so the biggest
Bletchley Park secret they had quarters
British codebreakers with American
assistance and safe world war the they
have a Soviet agent and his name is John
came from the fifth man in the Cambridge
ring of five but that dreadful film the
imitation game has is absolutely
ludicrous suggestions which not merely
said their evidence there is an enormous
amount of opposite evidence that what
can cross did was blackmail the great
codebreaker and in tearing into not
revealing that he was a Russian spy
because otherwise he would reveal that
he was gay and you know by the time year
that Steve did you just about bound to
win an Oscar which what happens in this
it's particularly but of course some
real the real story is much more
interesting because what I can cross was
doing apart from being a spy
he was a first British academic and for
all I know the first American academic
except that he wasn't an American to
take a real scholarly interest in
polygamy I mean it always helps to have
some practical experience as as well as
the theoretical interest so this is
still available
this is history of polygamy although the
illustration seems a little bit odd to
me but he got some absolutely terrific
reviews after the Second World War and
he got I think the best review ever
given to anybody from and this is a
large claim but I believe it may be to
the most original good blood good
reviews so this is Gregory to impart
from bigger to BBC yeah it's really like
books on polygamy
and here is that last is a book that
will strongly appeal to all pearly gates
so think how good the imitation game
might have been if they've concentrated
on the book about polygamy Oh another
lost opportunity now in the meantime of
course Stalin is keeping enormous
numbers of US diplomatic telegrams in
his farce a real problem because they're
too many really to find them far away
and because even though British security
was appalling it was in a different and
better classroom at the United States so
there is the man who at the time was
head of the least secure embassy in
Russian history ambassador William C
Bullock you may recall that it's not
until 1933 that the United States has
diplomatic representation and everywhere
he says is recorded repeatedly and and
at least his successor knew that he was
being bugged
and he actually Joseph E
Davis once he's given the evidence he's
saying thank goodness and as he says if
the Soviets had a dictaphone in the
embassy so much the better the sooner
they would find out that we were friends
not enemies oh dear
there so but it's not until 1944 and
I've seen the evidence I've seen the
original documents that it can still
somebody actually in the FBI that it
might be a good idea to have an
electronic sweep from the US Embassy in
Moscow and on day one they discover 120
hidden microphones which is about as
ready as you can discover in a
particular day but it cuz they to tell
you a tiny fraction of the total number
meanwhile of course we I really don't
think that at any point in world history
and I look forward to dealing with this
exaggerated claim from more sober
questioning afterwards there's ever been
a moment at which one power has known so
much about in one of his chief allies
they just couldn't take it all in so
here we are
Paul Roosevelt having millions ready to
go all the way to Yalta because it was
so much easier for the reference to
bogey Alta then it would have been
somewhere outside Russia and alas alas
you really gotta look at the photograph
to see that his life expectancy is
pretty limited
the livadia palace where I used to be
able to go and take lecture audiences is
not really where the big three met but
also where the US delegation stayed and
this is what stalin saw every day during
the do see asians so there is on the
left looking across he can see roosevelt
and immediately behind roosevelt he can
see one of the most valued spies know i
did used to be thought that Alger Hiss
was just extremely well-meaning and the
victim of American fascism but of course
actually he Wilson extremely successful
Soviet Tim it's fine
so having to deal with the continuous
bugging our photo via the American
Embassy with the livadia palace and
daily reports of the various agents in
the livadia palace it amounts to
intelligence overload the other kind
that must be difficult to deal with and
of course April 1945 you can see Molotov
trying not to looking
we pleased in the bottom left-hand
corner as Althea's presides at the UN
charter conference in San Francisco so
he could easily have become but
obviously did not become
secretary-general then fast forward to
1960 one of the things that the American
Embassy is given in Moscow at the
beginning of the of the Cold War is this
wooden model allegedly produced by
Soviet schoolchildren which he hangs
above his desk which is extremely
convenient and because it records
everything including George Karen's long
telegram that is sent to Washington and
only recently has it been discovered
that the British Embassy in Moscow
obviously had not quite the same level
of priority it's just as penetrated as
it had been in in Czarist times and I've
actually spoken to the former SAS
officer who was involved after the
Americans realized just how badly they
were penetrated British ambassador Sir
Frank Robertson really distinguished
British diplomat was persuaded that he
all familiar he was office to be checked
and as the man who did it has told me he
didn't believe it was possible and he
said you've got 20 minutes and at the
end of the 20 minutes this man was just
pulling from behind a skirting board a
one of the listening devices and
Robertson grabbed it from his hand and
started swearing extremely fluently into
it so talk about open diplomacy but get
us all in the Americans in 1962
Khrushchev complains to the US
ambassador that he's hostile to the
selling of oil and gas pipelines
American oil occurs but the only place
he could have caught this was from the
intercepted all the most likely place
intercepted and dispatches so now
another area in which we've got new
information which I think changes
there's this belief for many years that
what was going on is that the British
Labour Party had fully balanced view of
Russia
but these silly paranoids from British
security service mi5 tried to persuade
them that some Labour MPs were in hock
to Russia knows exactly that's what the
other way around
mi5 had begun to regard the leadership
of the British Labour Party as a little
bit excitable but in 1961 the Labour
leadership which for those who know
about the leadership leadership was
gates Kelly and George Brown as his
deputy and one or two others take em to
the house of commons this list of Labour
MPs they actually want to verify to keep
a check up so the ones they think are
actually CP members of the Communist
Party on the left-hand side you can see
the total of the left-hand side 18 and
then the possible ones 9 and mi5 just
thinks that the Labour leadership is
getting rid overheated so it doesn't pay
too much attention which is a pity
because the man in the top left-hand
corner wo Owen will Owen
Labour MP for warpath was in fact a
fully recruited Soviet bloc spy oh where
is his file well one of the smart things
that the Russians realised in the 1960s
is that it was far easier for Czech
intelligence was the British quite
rightly still had rather bad feelings
about Munich and it was so much easier
for Czechoslovak intelligence to recruit
MPs than it was for Russians so the
material is is now available as we've
been going through quite a lot of it
because it's fortunately we have one or
two Czechoslovak speakers not including
me years and years ago I I did have a
book which said to teach yourself check
and I abandoned hope in the middle of
chapter 3 they felt in many cases and so
on
so that's where will owns file is now
and it is pretty exciting yeah that
stuff
his official code name was Lee but he
was so greedy right up to the point when
he was leaving the embassy he would
empty the cigar box and put it his
inside
so they gave him the alternative name of
really bastard
and then here is a name which used to be
famous infamous
in Britain one of Wilson's ministers not
the cabinet minister at the end of the
1960's were confident that he would rise
to become Foreign Secretary and he tells
he tells the SDB and again his file is
available that he'll be found more use
to them but he's also a confidence
trickster and the older amongst us will
recall that he said the last British
Labour MP to fake his his own suicide he
he left his carefully arranged clothes
on a Florida beach and didn't talk but
all the time he had gone with his woman
friend not his wife to Australia where
he was he was tracked down so and now
it's it's the point I want to come to
now is the thing that I think Western
intelligence got most wrong during the
of the Cold War it confused the frequent
though not invariable success of Russian
intelligence collection with the
inability to understand what the meaning
of political intelligence was so what
you currently get at times of crisis is
the belief that the United States is
preparing a nuclear first strike now and
once again the evidence is not in tap
June 1968 shelepin who was reckoned to
be about the smartest head of the KGB
before and top off tells crucially comes
round to the Kremlin to say it in the
CIA it is known that the leadership of
the Pentagon is convinced of the need to
initiate a war with the Soviet Union
quote as soon as possible where does
this come from well it comes from
General Jack da Rippa
or as he was known at the time general
Curtis LeMay head of Strategic Air
Command and afterwards the KGB was
picking up the kind of things that after
a few cigars and several bottles of
bourbon as an exaggeration just several
glasses of Bevin general Curtis LeMay
would say you know why don't we finish
them off and they okay
we couldn't fail to realize this this is
just the kind of thing he said after
dinner as opposed to a carefully
prepared strategic plan and so this is
of course dr. Strangelove the most
brilliant film ever made about him
nuclear warfare but I haven't got time
to but it's the GRU as well now the
Russians themselves have released this
the giu later tells Christoph that the
United States have planned to launch an
even surprise nuclear attack in
September 1961 but have been deterred at
the last moment because Soviet nuclear
tests appeared to indicate that the
Soviet nuclear arsenal was more powerful
and therefore they would be able to
realized and therefore they'd be able to
deal with a second strike and it's at
this very moment in March 1962 that
Khrushchev takes the decision to put
missile bases in Cuba I can't prove
those in connection but it would be
pretty old if there was no connection at
all so what else is crossed off using
well he's continuing the tradition of
assassination operations this is not
central but it's nonetheless a
continuous part and of course the the
main targets are the traitors now the
definition of traitor and changes over
the years but the ones that they were
most anxious about were Ukrainian
nationalist leaders who were in exile
and mainly they were in exile in Germany
now one's only got to look at the
bungles of this produced to see that
even though it's not wholly Bunkley now
anybody can regard the bungles in the
last few years is out of the historical
tradition
I don't know so here we are Nicolai
Koslov KGB assassin sent to West Germany
to kill Ukrainian emigrated but he
doesn't because he makes friends with
the man who he was supposed to
assassinate who's the man who doesn't
look at tally amused Yogi Akal ovitch on
the on the right and then gives a press
conference with this kind of stuff may
look pretty straightforward now but
believe me I electrically operating guns
with cyanide bullets concealed in
cigarette packets was beyond the
imagination of James Bond
those days so the bungling is right back
to the linen era and beyond any bundle
which I believe is the poutine so here
are the current bundlers all right you
rarely see assassins there having such a
good time these are the ones that went
to Salisbury and of course they're
breakings by their expressions and
things that they're wearing all they
other kind of stuff having believed
they've just a you know left poison
behind which was disposed of and they
are both heroes of Russia and Putin
doesn't have pick'em and they're there
of course I mean in the entire history
of bogus covenant stories I mean it may
be possible but I really challenge
colleagues afterwards to think of
anything sillier then oh we we were
really impressed by the fact that
Salisbury Cathedral has a spire which is
taller than Norwich Cathedral
I come from Norwich and we're so pleased
we only have the second tallest by
because that means we have no problem
with assassination operations just again
that's the complete lack of cover and I
think the argument that there's a
complete lack of coming because they're
brilliant is suggestive look at the man
on the right Alexander Michigan alias
Alexander Petrov he really does look
like a special-needs assassin so these
are ones they were after and of course
they were but the fact that Michigan's
Mercedes the paper trail including the
speeding tickets should be available in
a way in which to the best of my
knowledge members are both British and
American intelligence who have picked up
lots of speeding tickets I don't think
any British or American intelligence
officer was 11 left such a trail behind
now you know good news this is a man
that I've had a lot to do with or did
not do boys his death one of the the
most admirable things about the
extraordinary archives of the KGB is
they lost control of them
why well not wholly it happened to this
man but I see limit rocket I mean
totally the story at great length so
what I could do so again but over a
period of 15 years because he was in
charge of moving as a foreign
intelligence archive from the Lubyanka
to the new head quarters in a cinema on
the outskirts of Moscow he was able to
collect this huge intelligence our code
but he saw himself all the time as a
whistleblower he wanted it to be known
the only way could be known was getting
into the West but until the Soviet Union
fell apart there was no way of getting
it to the west and then what happens
when it does fall out fall apart he
essentially dressed as a street person
as you can see here has a burrow along
which has copies of secret documents at
the bottom which he knows will check out
because they're a give they're the real
identities of series of Russian illegals
and he knows that British and American
intelligence will be able to check so
well then on the top of that he has
dirty washing and then from clean
clothing and then highly spiced sausage
juice and so on and we exactly the kind
of think that he had correctly would
mean that they the immigration
immigration authorities only just been
established would mean that they
wouldn't look at his newspaper and then
he tries to get into an American Embassy
but so many other people are trying to
get into America and was to get visas he
doesn't he goes along to a British
Embassy in one of the Baltic States and
he goes in with his pull along and he
pulls out some of this stuff burning
from beneath the sausages and the dirty
clothing and he asked to see and a young
diplomat and my goodness she saw her
things which a lot of others wouldn't
see first of all I mean by the way she's
now an ambassador but she doesn't wish
her identity to be known so I'm not
going to to mention it and she realized
this that this material will check out
if it's accurate so she takes the
material and then says something which
only a British diplomat could say and
gives me an extraordinary sense
of personal pride which in the BRIC
cetera is pretty rare nowadays so what
she says to him is would you like a cup
of tea isn't it wonderful
I'd say say that now and as though he
had his first to have a cup of British
tea the material was checked out he came
to England with his huge lorry load of
stuff and his wife and son and I met him
and we lived happily ever after
now there is that's the book that I
wrote with him you can you can see he's
disguised then very well disguised and
this is well the FBI and the CIA say
about it
just extraordinary I mean it's not
everything there there's nothing about
em Dora
for example there's some very
interesting stuff on San Marino and most
other countries of the world though and
it's now available I'm glad to say since
our book came out it's available in
Churchill College archive Cambridge and
just next to the papers of Winston
Churchill and and those are the three
collections of papers worth of the most
consulted at Churchill nowadays now what
do we get out of it well here's what
must change my mind
I had the view as I think many people do
that the illegals you know fantastic
technical achievement as in those silly
films of the Americans to manage to
present yourself as another
nationalities so successful as you'll
remember in the case of the ghost
stories that some of the children of the
illegals don't even realize was their
parents are Russian rather than American
an incredible technical feat which in
the West really hasn't been worth it
nowhere it really makes a difference
isn't the Soviet bloc because anytime
there was dissidents as for example in
1968 in the in the Prague Spring
illegals who managed to pass themselves
off as British journalists German
businessmen and so on would say to the
leaders of the distance is what could we
do to help you and so
this is the list on the left-hand side
one of whom grow off is the code name of
God is his elder brother by the way of
the people pretending to be Westerners
and it was a brilliantly simple device
there's no major district outbreak in
Eastern Europe which is not penetrated
but I think it'd be illegal so there is
Yuri Andropov this was a period in which
he didn't get to be Soviet leader
without being terminally ill as you can
and then now back to Putin and Tim I am
reaching some kind of conclusion so just
the idea that this is someone as he
Simpson committed was just absolutely
fascinated by Russian intelligence
history so fascinated that as he himself
has described at the age of 16 he goes
up to the only ugly buildings in
Petersburg which is the KGB headquarters
it was always said that him it was an
ugly building is an ugly building but
there was a wonderful view from the top
you could see all the way to Siberia and
then you can see is a failure of it
having got into the job that he had
always wanted he's not sent to one of
the prime jobs he's sent to East Germany
which as you can see from the expression
because he doesn't know he was speaking
at a photograph he finds less than
fascinating now we know he's a failure
how do we know he's a failure because
this man was not a failure
Yevgeniy through my cough who was
leading international relations expert
and made with a great reputation of the
West who becomes SVR director in the
five years after the fall of the old
regime and he's he says afterwards about
Putin I never met Putin or heard a word
about him but he was so unsuccessful why
would you I mean it had to be of average
ability in the field of foreign
prereq off to have heard of him so even
nonetheless he's always been an
astonishingly good it did intriguing his
way through whatever job he wanted
the job he wanted he wanted to be head
of the FSB
Intel successor of the KGB and he is and
then Yeltsin no as you see doesn't look
incredibly pleased ranted makes M him
successor as president and who is he
surrounded by well in particular his
three intelligence chiefs all of the EU
and not simply the EU sanctions list now
the the main media not simply media
preoccupation over the last couple of
years there's been the attempt Russian
attempt to interfere in recent Russian
elections was following concerned I mean
the best report that has so far be
produced because although there are
others in prospect as the one that was
produced under the Obama regime and
there is no reason it seems to me to
doubt its general conclusion Russian
President Vladimir Putin ordered an
influence campaign in 2016 aimed at the
u.s. presidential election Russia's
goals were to undermine public faith in
the US democratic process denigrate
Secretary Clinton harm her electability
and potential presidency we further
assess Putin and the Russian government
developed a clear preference for
president elect Trump that's it and it
was obvious even even before the last
American presidential
now at one level there is nothing new
about this I and others have published a
lot of these forgeries and broadly
speaking the KGB you never saw an
election it didn't want to influence and
that is half a troll the making of the
Soviet bloc these countries that did not
wish to be communist but within a few
years of coaching of their newly founded
common intelligence services were
capable of producing 99% majorities
nothing I've had Russian Foreign
Intelligence has achieved outside the
former Soviet bloc and because we go to
enormous trouble to produce forgeries
like this I and others have published a
number of them this is an attempt to
show that they were secret relations
with the apartheid regime and plenty of
others but these forgeries produced very
little impact
so it's the combination of a traditional
Russian intelligence obsession combined
with social media which has changed the
influence
now of course and that as always an
intelligence needs to do is to bring
together the open sources with the
intelligence sources and what we're
dealing with is a level of autocratic
narcissism which there is very few
comparisons that one can make when in
the last few hundred years
but the last person before put him and
to believe that he looked better with
his shirt off was Mussolini and the last
person before Mussolini was a Napoleon
that this was caliber armed attack
camera the portrait shows not Napoleon
well it shows Napoleon's head but the
body is a fit young Italian could deal
fitter than muscley lay there so they
then mostly not time to go through all
the open source material but it's only
when one puts together I mean the stuff
that gives Putin extraordinary pleasure
would be regarded by any of the rest of
us just pathetic
I mean to feel the need to pose in his
early 60s as one of Russia's leading ice
hockey players you know I mean I don't
know if there's any therapy that could
deal with that but there is read Russian
it says Putin on the back and he's just
scoring Li eighths of his latest girl 8
girls in the 80 in the six trials by the
National Hockey League all-stars over
the over the second team and if I had an
hour and the good news is that I don't I
could produce an endless list of equally
as silly photographs which outmuscle any
muscle any any day of the week now
here's a side of Putin which for some
reason a lot of Western commentators
seem to be in
denial now exactly its significance I
don't pretend to understand because the
all the compartments in Putin's brain
invade of them see how they actually
come together and I think there must be
a problem for him but he likes photos
like this his mother reveals in 2000 he
revealed them 2012 10 years earlier
before she died his mother had revealed
that she'd had him baptized in secret
and if it had not been in secret of
course he would never be allowed into
the KGB or had already been in he would
have been kicked out but so what we what
we find out and it's not difficult my
students go to this place you can go to
divine service there Oh Putin has
established its a basilica it's not a
Cathedral but it is the Basilica of
sense of fear in central Moscow quite
close to Red Square and furthermore
patrushev who's the National Security
Advisor they've presented the the church
with these icons have some jords the
Dragon Slayer and again not something
for any possible comparison pretty sure
before most other intelligence history
so Chiefs of the intelligence service is
able to go along to divine service with
piltan from time to time so there is
fresh coffe you could tell that fred
cough has not been to Easter services
all out frequently but there is with
with Putin and there are lots of others
that I could produce the good news is
I'm not going to and he gets along
astonishingly well with successive
patriarchs alexei ii was with Alma KGB
agent whose name was drawn or thrush but
again that is not I think to belittle
him entirely because in a Russian
tradition giving unto Caesar those
things that belong to Caesar and giving
unto God those things that belong to God
there's some it's it's possible for
people's lives to separate line so I'm
perfectly prepared to believe all there
are wholly convinced that patriarchs can
have
a genuine spiritual life while having a
sycophantic relationship with the Putin
regime so here is Putin praising the
Orthodox Church for creating the spirit
of patriotism among young Russians
it was labor ger to be anti-christian
and now it's de rigueur to be Christian
and this is the current patriarch Kiril
with whom he gets on as you can see
extremely well and Kirill calls Putin's
leadership and there are many other
quotations like this a miracle of God
now here's one of the problems Putin is
obsessed with bling but particular kind
of bling which I'll come on to but Kira
likes a bit of bling himself and how do
we know this well because the
airbrushing skills have been largely
lost in the Photoshop era so Kira likes
a fancy watch although not nearly as
fancy watches as Putin adults Putin
wouldn't be seen dead in a $30,000 watch
but the Carroll would be seen alive on
the right hand side what happened was
that after complained that Kira was
wearing a $30,000 watches his office
published a photograph which shows that
the particular meeting where he was
supposed to at least $30,000 watch he
wasn't wearing watch at all but just
look in the heavily polished mahogany
table you can see an exact image of the
box that he wasn't wearing and so then
the office had to say they'd been a bit
of a mistake and they published the
correct photograph on the the left hand
side which shows the watches as well as
the the image now the best way of paying
and noticing they kind of blinged and
Putin particularly likes is when he
makes a speech he holds his hand up like
this and there has been a very scholarly
study of the watches that he wore over a
four months period now I can't identify
this watch but I know you wouldn't be
able to get it for $30,000 so a
suspension a wonderful month period the
value of the watches that he wore was
six times that of his annual
salary which is a suitable point at
which to end and I look forward to
questions thank you very much no no
actually sometimes I'm against it
Marilee knows who to pick yes thank you
presser Andrew thanks again for a great
talk I the ambassador ambassador Mayer
in 1905 announced that the u.s. knew
that the Russians were intercepting and
decoding what made him do that why
wasn't there a misinformation or a
disinformation campaign first did he
know that they knew that he knew well my
view is I'm welcome other contributions
from the audience is that the statement
paid no attention to the confidentiality
of American diplomatic communications
the example that I produced in my first
lecture is the way that the you didn't
need WikiLeaks in the last generation of
the 19th century because it was all done
by the State Department so that every
year they produced a collection and
published a collection of the most
interesting dispatches sent by American
ambassadors over the previous generation
and produces the the example from a Yale
ambassador by saying that none of them
any longer dared send back to Washington
they're serious thoughts it's it's just
very difficult to put oneself back into
a period and that this was true in
ancient institutions on both sides of
the Atlantic
in which paying attention to
security was just not something that one
did so here's a very short personal
confession and when I was in here to
tear and the 1980s I own Cambridge
College it's the best of my belief and
my belief is I think correct I was the
first person to lock the fire room door
and indeed the senior tutors door when I
left
it's just that was so distrustful to
lock a door which would prevent students
from going and looking at their and
their their files it and again we didn't
use to lock out bikes and so on the the
Foreign Office did not have and this can
be established from documents where that
in difficulty at all not merely did it
not have a security department it did
not have a single security officer
before the First World War
so this meant that embassies in a whole
series of places were producing more
British diplomatic correspondence that
the Russians could keep track of just
one example but it's one which the the
documentation is I think by now
reasonably well known the the British
ambassador's successive British
ambassador's in in in Rome their valet
and their main value and then his his
brother would remove stuff from the the
ambassador's to say it's not difficulty
in case of one of the safes because it
didn't have a back but there was one
that they had to be open from the front
and then they would pass it on to the to
the Russians and then because the
Ambassador didn't notice what's going on
ladies how to give copies to him Vasily
near as well now the detail role this is
extremely well known so I think that
difficulty that I have and I suspect
that other people have as well it's just
putting oneself back into an era in
which just thinking about security at
all was so alien that people didn't
is all of the hold on
so of course I have to note that this is
the Henry L Stimson lecture and I wonder
whether you'd comment on his alleged
comment that gentlemen don't read other
gentleman's mail and then his decision
to do away with the coding came I keep
moving around and I apologized for that
but I the first 10 minutes of my first
lecture aware were on that but what I
find a particular interest is that he
changes his mind more than any other
major US official and I think the last
century or so because when he becomes
Secretary of State in a Republican
regime in 1929 he probably didn't say
gentlemen do not read each other's mail
but he certainly thought it and he he
describes the the practice of
intercepting the correspondence of
ambassadors and other invoice accredited
to Washington as entirely unacceptable
deeply unethical and it is he who closes
down the second agency popularly and
known for the few who knew about it as
black chamber and then no if you look as
I've had the privilege of doing and his
Diaries at the beginning of the Second
World War
partly encouraged by his association
with the the British he can't get enough
secant so there's just well one example
that I recommend mow until there's more
than one but there's just one that I'll
mention August 1940 he puts in his diary
that American code breakers doing
something which is so exciting and so
important that he can't even put it in
his diary what's he referring to the
breaking of the Japanese diplomatic code
it's time for purple so you know Walter
what a career I mean someone whose first
experience of secrets of skullenbones
and who's finally experienced of major
secrets was the detonation of the first
atomic bomb and in in Hiroshima the
material in the the Stimson
well simply his is-is-is dari is
something I have to restrain myself from
giving any more examples out but I've
given just a taste I hope and there's a
question behind you personal income
perhaps you name professor I didn't I
didn't know I don't I'm not a student of
this my name is Jean Connelly I'm a
student I was a student at Yale in 1953
a lots happened since then I think is
there anything new in the intelligence
business is there anything that can
still surprise you because what you've
said surprises the life out of me and I
don't know what to think
can you tell me should I sleep tonight
or not yes I would I mean I've been
saying that when I ever I switch on
American television I see they're these
wonderful pillows which guarantee a good
night's sleep
and it only only $10,000 I'm a little
bit skeptical but I'll move back to the
point of view of course 1953 is a good
date to mention because the first person
to diagnose clearly the problem others
must have sensitive before Mechele and
Kent you're a great historian but of
this university but also somebody who
understood the underlying problem and
the underlying problem over the
centuries is simply this that
intelligence history is not linear it's
sometimes worse in one century and then
it was 200 years before I'm given one
example but I'll give another in these
lectures the the the reason is
straightforward and it's pretty
difficult for all of us to learn from
experience but if you're in a profession
which doesn't even know what the the
experience was you're going to get it
considerably worse so
I give this example simply because it's
a current centenary so in a few days
time we are celebrating and I think it's
a subject for celebrating at the end of
the First World War
well there is to my mind no question and
I don't really believe that in what
looks that the evidence would arrive at
a different conclusion
Woodrow Wilson the best-educated
president in American history is so far
and it's difficult to imagine many more
presidents of American universities
becoming president in the immediate
future his understanding of intelligence
doesn't begin to compare with that of
George Washington and his contemporary
at the beginning of the of the the
Second World War and I've argued this
with I hope more than adequate detail in
my latest book h/h Asquith is not in the
same class as Pitt the elder and Pitt
the Younger so you know in no other
profession would you find highly
intelligent well-educated people as at
Bletchley Park breaking Hitler's codes
who had no idea that every time we are
threatened with an invasion slight
exaggeration but every time we have
threatened with a really major invasion
Napoleon at the beginning of the
nineteenth century the period when all
those Martello tower breaking those
codes and the people who broke his codes
at the slightest idea that before the
the armada philip ii codes were were
were being broken so this is an area
which proves more than any other that i
can think of they all platitude in all
platitudes by definition are true that
those who do not understand past
mistakes are doomed to repeat them Pearl
Harbor is a pretty good example of that
so you were there next question I think
from the political science department I
had a question the first would be since
you and thank you very much for the
comments on the Russians but since
you've studied this function over the
centuries have you come up with some
idea as to what two or three aspects of
a country over government are essential
to become really a first-class player in
the intelligence game and the second
question is whether you think that high
tech currently has in fact deeply
influenced the intelligence game and in
what way well two of his question first
I think first of all let's see it
essential to be a multiparty democracy
in all autocratic systems autocrats are
told what they want to hear now as far
back as Elizabeth the first which was an
extremely successful period and well
zing him when he told us something which
he didn't want to hear she would take
off her slipper and she was a very good
shot and catchy monkey and on the side
of the other head now anybody who tells
tell him something that they didn't want
to hear this would not simply be a bad
career move it would be a life
shortening experience now as as for the
difference that current media has made
it simply or simply is not the correct
qualifier it's essentially the another
form of the problem of you've got a
wonderful intelligent source now how do
you understand it and the social social
media I think is a step backwards in
human understanding anyway because those
who have access to the Sterling Library
and other places already have formidable
access to
reliable information it had simply meant
that a higher proportion of the
information available to educated young
people is inaccurate than any previous
moment in 20th century British or
American history that is my view which I
do not expect to be a universal view you
mentioned his name in the you're just
you know the previous answer you were
giving Walsingham where would you rank
Sir Francis Walsingham in intelligence
history I would rank him very high
although why he was so good is more
typical question it was partly to do
with the fact that you know there is a
real threat I mean the fact that Queen
Elizabeth the first survived at all is
simply astonishing they were threats to
assassinator which very nearly succeeded
two of her contemporaries kings of
France they were both assassinated her
successor James supposed to of England
James the sixth of Scotland were only a
few days after Guy Fawkes Day and
suppose people in this room will know
the nearest we have to a national
celebration his Guy Fawkes Day when the
King his ministers and a huge number of
other people were almost blown up by 26
barrels of gunpowder the Marana
discovered that the at the last moment
so he the very fact that Wolsey him who
combines the jobs on Foreign Minister
foreign secretary and in intelligence
chief gets to see Elizabeth the first
every day is an indication of of the
priorities but the assassination attempt
and the threat from the Armada could not
have been dealt with without very good
intelligence that was very well built
with and I will just give one example of
I showed some pictures
a couple of days three days ago which
made the point in in a different
way but quit Elizabeth the first
personally contacts our chief code
breaker and thanks him gives him a
pension so one of the points I was
trying to make in earlier lectures is
that the chief code breakers depending
on the country but Britain and France
come to mind
Venice got more personal praise from the
rulers than any intelligent any any code
breakers in 20th and 21st century
there's just this so curious belief that
anything to do with code breaking and
signals intelligence must be more
influential in the 20th century than it
was in the 16th but the handling of them
SIGINT before they Armada was a
different class for the handling of
SIGINT before Pearl Harbor oh good I am
curious to know about countries that you
you haven't mentioned like India for
instance Pakistan oh yes those in South
America what can you tell us about that
I did mention India in 91 but not enough
but let me resume my main point which I
can't think of any other area of human
knowledge in which the Greeks and the
Romans was so far behind they main agen
contemporaries now obviously Sansa is
the the Chinese sage and correspond
contemporary of Confucius is the main
one but the art of Shastra the Indian
equivalent is another I think striking
example know what happens of course is
that those classic texts get forgotten
and they're only rediscovered in the
20th century and they're largely
rediscovered at least initially by
Western scholars and you mentioned
Pakistan well there's time for me to
give just one example thank goodness my
first-hand experience of warfare has
been astonishingly small
but in the final stages 1987 of the
Russian war and it is fair to call it
that on Afghanistan I went along and I
went to have lunch with some friends at
the headquarters of the Khyber rifles
the way to get is perfectly
straightforward you grow up the Khyber
Pass and it's the third big boulder from
the top you turn right new gear around a
corner and you see the Khyber rifles in
kilts during a sword dance and you made
to feel really welcome anyway I'll cut
all the rest except to say that after
lunch we went and were able to look at a
soviet-era attack on the Hadean
positions in the the next Valley and
this man who was a senior in in is I
seen a Pakistani intelligence officer I
said you must have briefed hundreds of
people over the last 10 12 years here
and i said dim who would you say was the
smartest and he said what an easy
question Richard Nixon I'm not going to
attempt to defend how I write that but
just that strategic ability to grasp the
strategic and issues anyway I won't go
any further than that but I was
impressed by his answer
this is perhaps a different area of
intelligence but when Ronald Reagan took
office he engaged in this huge military
buildup designed to bring the Russians
to the bargaining table and my question
is was that build-up really necessary or
were the Soviets willing and eager to
get there anyway for reasons of their
own mind they would be no to both of
those questions but let me expand him a
little bit and what he he failed to
realize he wasn't the only one and that
if you talk about the Russians as an
evil empire you know if you knew if we
had Melander blade that they reacted
rhetoric like that before they would and
he would have realized that they would
think that he really was preparing a
nuclear first strike which they did
operation rearm and the main aim of
Soviet foreign intelligence was to
collect in the United States and this
made and I was written above all
evidence of this non preparation and of
course the the senior Soviet
intelligence officers in London and
Washington didn't dare say that that was
all crazy but to be fair to Reagan he
realized what he'd done in his Diaries
he says that no the Russians had no
reason to be afraid but they were and it
is I think not an exaggeration to say
that after he had been given the the
intelligence in November 1983 of the
extent of the Russian fears he tones
down to rhetoric almost from one day to
the next
the phrase evil empire is never produced
by him after November 1980 83 so it the
the fact that a he made a terrible
mistake is it seems to me
it's a significant period compensated by
the fact that he does something which
most people who make terrible mistakes
do not do as soon as I realized that
he's made a terrible mistake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]